- If I ever go to his house,
I'm takin' the ball.
- You gonna steal it?
- Yeah, I'm gonna steal it.
- Brett, Brett,
hide the ball, man.
- I'm stealin' that, for real.
- If Sean McVay
has breathed near you
you're gonna be a head coach in the NFL.
- Right.
Troll him, Saints fans!
- Look how dumb he looks in that.
♪♪♪
Welcome to "Simms & Lefkoe,"
and it is the best weekend
of NFL football of the year,
divisional round.
You've always felt this way?
- Yes.
I mean, the last two weekends.
I mean, Wild Card Weekend's great.
- Yeah.
- But this one is the one
I really look forward to.
It's the eight best teams
in football.
- Without a doubt.
- And I think we literally
got the eight best in there
this year,
which is refreshing to me.
- Are you saying my Eagles
are one of the eight best
after a year of slander?
-Yeah, I'm gonna say it.
Hey, you were the better team
on Sunday afternoon.
I know that.
- Appreciate that.
- And I'm so sick of hearing
about you and the Eagles.
I can't even tell you.
- Oh my gosh.
- That's just the truth.
- When you watch all the games
on TV this weekend,
all the pregame shows
other than laughing
at bad jokes—no offense
to your dad, or you this
weekend, sorry—are also
gonna make it all about
the quarterbacks, and we get it.
But it's the trenches
where games are won and lost
and some of the best
offensive lines are still alive.
- Yes.
- So these are the real matchups
for divisional round playoffs.
First one, Chiefs-Colts.
It's just not Andrew Luck
and Patrick Mahomes. It's—
- It's going to be
Quenton Nelson
the guard for
the Indianapolis Colts.
- All-Pro.
- All-Pro versus Chris Jones
defensive tackle,
14-plus sacks.
But yes, that is going to be a
huge point in the football game.
The Chiefs secondary stinks.
- Yes.
- You have to be able to get pressure
on Andrew Luck with your front four.
- Good luck.
- Good luck gettin' there,
exactly right.
But that will be a key matchup
that I watch
especially being up the middle
getting into
the quarterback's face
where he can't step up
or see passing lanes.
That night, Rams-Cowboys.
It's gonna be about Dak
and Jared Goff.
They came out
in the same draft class.
- Or Gurley and Ezekiel Elliott.
- But what's the real matchup?
- The real matchup goes up front
once again.
You got the Dallas Cowboys
offensive line
arguably one
of the best in football
but Zack Martin versus Aaron Donald.
Are you kidding me?
- Zack Martin was the original
Quenton Nelson.
- Exactly right.
I would say he's the second-best
guard in football now
behind Quenton Nelson
and Aaron Donald.
Come on, let's be serious.
He is going to be
Defensive Player of the Year.
He is the best defensive player
in the league.
That matchup will be huge
because when you have
a Zack Martin
where a team like Dallas can go,
"We don't need to help you.
We think you can handle him
by yourself," that, of course
frees up the rest
of the O-line to do things.
But if it becomes an issue
and then they have to help—
- Changes the whole game.
- Then mismatches happen
in other areas.
- Who wins that matchup?
- I gotta go with Aaron Donald.
- You can't not.
I was gonna yell at you
if you went Zack.
- He's an unstoppable force.
Right.
- Patriots-Chargers.
Philip Rivers, Tom Brady, oldest
matchup of quarterbacks ever.
- Right.
- I'm already annoyed by it.
What is the real matchup?
- I always look,
in playoff football
for the New England Patriots
the first guy I go to other than Brady—
- Gronk.
- Is Gronk, right.
Gronk is the key piece
for the New England offense.
- I know what you're gonna say.
- And you know.
- You're gonna say there's
a Gronk-stopper on the Chargers.
- There is. Derwin James is a guy
I would look at to go.
That matchup will be key
not only just
in coverage too, Lefkoe.
I mean, we've talked about it.
Gronkowski is one of the best
blocking tight ends
in the history of football,
and Derwin James
plays basically middle
linebacker for the Chargers.
- So his ability to—
- I'm pickin' Derwin James
in this matchup.
- In the pass game,
I certainly am.
I think—but the run game
is where I worry
about the Chargers a little bit
but either way,
fascinating matchup.
- And the Sunday night game.
Interesting.
- Hmm.
- It's the Saints and the Eagles.
- Oh.
- And, you know
did you know
that Nick Foles and Drew Brees
went to the same
high school in Texas?
- I did.
Austin Westlake.
Yes, I was very aware of that.
- You ready to hear about that
for seven hours?
- Yeah.
- But what's the actual matchup
in that game?
- I hate to be boring,
but I'm goin' up front again.
And I think that's
the great thing about
the playoffs right now.
We have a lot
of the top-tier D-lines
and offensive lines
still available.
That shows you how important
it is to win those wars.
But your man, Fletcher Cox—
- Who I believe is up there
with Aaron Donald
as the best defensive tackle
in the NFL.
- No doubt, yes.
- He's above Chris Jones.
- Yes, he's—as a total player,
I agree.
He is above Chris Jones.
There's no doubt about that.
But him versus Andrus Peat.
- Your man crush.
- My man, yes.
Big legs, big butt, all of that.
- One of the greatest
combine body performances
in the history of the league.
- It really is fascinating.
But he, again,
is a top-notch guard in the NFL.
The Saints wanna run the ball.
And again, just like we talked
with Donald and Zack Martin
the ability to be able to trust
a guy like Andrus Peat and go
"Oh, no, we think you can handle
Fletcher Cox by yourself"—
- Now you can have
an extra receiver,
an extra running back.
- Exactly right.
You don't have to move
the offensive line
in certain directions.
I think all four of these
matchups will really dictate
a lot of what goes on
in the full game.
- Yeah, but you're takin',
you're takin'—
You took the defender,
you're takin' Fletcher Cox?
- I am taking Fletcher Cox.
- Simms just said the Eagles
are gonna beat the Saints.
- No, I didn't.
Come on, Saints, let's do it!
- Stop.
- I don't wanna hear
Lefkoe anymore!
- Stop.
- Let's go Saints!
- I'm George Kittle.
- And I'm Trent Taylor.
- And you're watching
"Simms & Lefkoe."
- Thank you so much, Trent Taylor
and George Kittle
the second-best
football friends I know.
- Hey, Kittle, I heard
you been trollin' my boy
Lefkoe over there—
- He DMs me.
- With DMs.
You better watch it,
or I'll show you
who the real king
of the arm farm is, man.
You better watch it.
[Laughing]
- Aaron Rodgers has a new head
football coach
and it is the former, now,
offensive coordinator
of the Titans, Matt LaFleur.
Young coach that was under
Kyle Shanahan and Sean McVay
and at this point,
for NFL coaches
if Sean McVay
has breathed near you
you're gonna be a head coach
in the NFL.
- Right.
- I am very disappointed.
I felt like the Titans offense
was not that great this year.
If anything, I thought
Mariota regressed.
Am I crazy to believe that?
- I don't think you're crazy
to believe that.
I wanna make sure
I get this right here.
Matt LaFleur does have,
I've always thought this
the potential to be
a head coach.
- OK.
- He is that type of guy.
I think this is way
too premature, though
to be put in this position
as the head coach
of Aaron Rodgers
and the Green Bay Packers.
And, yes, to your point,
I would argue
the biggest weakness
of the Titans team last year
was probably their pass offense.
So just because you worked
for McVay or Shanahan
doesn't make you, like,
the grand master
of offense as well.
- Follow-up question.
- Right.
Go ahead.
- Is the offense better
than the offense
that Rodgers was playing in?
- Yes, he will have more ideas
than Mike McCarthy.
He certainly will.
That's where McVay and Shanahan
and his background with them
will help him.
But this is what people
are missing.
- To be the head coach, though.
Like, Kyle Shanahan was an OC
of top-five offenses
with Matt Schaub
and Andre Johnson
and the Houston Texans.
- RG3.
- OK, and then he went to RG3
with the Washington Redskins.
Then went to Atlanta
and had the MVP season.
- You're right.
- McVay built a great offense
in Washington
that took over for Shanahan—
- With Kirk Cousins, yeah.
- And was one of the best
play-callers for a few years
before he became the head coach.
So we're all just looking
for this young guy
but you also gotta look at
results and facts of the matter
and I think that's where
it's being missed right now.
They're just going, like
you said, "Young? McVay?
Shanahan? Hired!"
- I hope they get a good DC too
but, really, my big hope—
- Keep Pettine.
- Yeah, you're right.
- Right.
- I just wanna make sure,
if Aaron Rodgers and LaFleur
are spending those late nights
in the office
diagramming up some plays—
- Sure.
- It could be cool
if they grow together.
- It could be, no doubt.
- But right now, I'm underwhelmed.
- It's just a little early.
I agree.
- We wanted McDaniels.
- Yeah, we did.
- Yeah.
- Now, I know you played
one game in the playoffs
and you had a moment
that was almost spectacular.
- Right.
- Sorry, Edell Shepherd.
I don't wanna
bring up bad things.
- Yeah, don't.
- But if you could imagine
making an incredible play
in the playoffs
it's gotta be like the greatest
feeling of all time.
- The playoffs in general
are the greatest feeling
of all time.
I didn't even win
my playoff game.
I played a pretty good game
against the Washington Redskins
but I knew the second I walked
into the stadium that day
I said, "Man, there is something
different around here today."
Everybody's jazzed up.
We came out for warm-ups
and the stadium was 80 percent full,
and I was just like
"OK, we're ready for
some big-time football here."
And LaVar Arrington and people
were yellin' at me
and I was like,
"Wow, they're mad already
and we haven't even started."
So there is definitely
a different buzz.
- And that's just the playoffs.
- Yeah, seriously.
- So our buddy LaMarr Woodley
he made one of those incredible
plays in the Super Bowl
and you can just feel
how awesome
it must've been to do it.
- I'd have a shrine in my house
just about the one play.
- Just for you.
- Yeah, just be like
"Damn, look at what
I did to win us a Super Bowl."
- I would say in, like,
the pantheon of Super Bowls
Steelers-Cardinals was, like,
one of the greatest
most exciting games I've ever seen.
- Super Bowl 43, yeah.
- You ended that Super Bowl.
So, like, take me through
the play, man.
Like, that s--t was nuts.
- You know, it was, like,
we had a timeout before
and I remember Coach Tomlin
pullin' us out, like
"Woo, we need a big play."
You know, that's the kinda
s--t you see on TV, in a movie.
Like, "Come on, man,
we need a big play from you."
Like, man, I ain't finna make
no big play.
Like, "All right, Coach,
you know I got you."
You know, they got
Larry Fitzgerald
tallest receiver out there
at the time.
Kurt Warner can throw the ball.
- Yeah.
- So the best thing to do
is to stop the ball,
like in basketball.
Stop the guy with the ball.
So I'm rushin',
and Kurt Warner's lookin' at me
so as I went out,
he dipped in, so I dipped out
and I seen Kurt reaching back,
and I just kinda like—
- Superman.
- Supermanned it.
- Yeah.
- Hit the ball out,
sack, forced fumble.
Brett Keisel jumped on the ball.
- There's probably two moments
where the crowd goes nuts, right?
One when you smack it out
and then, like,
the realization afterwards.
- You know what?
It didn't feel real at first.
Going into that game, we felt
like we was gonna win anyways
so I already had my camera
on the sideline.
- What do you mean,
you brought a camera down?
- After halftime,
I snuck it on the field.
- You snuck it on your jersey?
- I snuck it on the field.
- So were you doing, like,
selfies?
- Hell yeah.
I was recording myself.
And I remember Brett Keisel
asking me, said
"LaMarr, man,
you want the football?"
I said, "Nah, man, keep it."
Why in the hell did I say that?
- Yeah, what were you thinking?
- He caught me
at an exciting time.
- Bein' a good teammate.
- Yeah.
And to this day,
I'm still tryin'
to get that damn ball back.
If I ever go to his house,
I'm takin' the ball.
- You gonna steal it?
- Yeah, I'm gonna steal it.
- Brett, Brett,
hide the ball, man.
- I'm stealin' that, for real.
- [Laughing]
- When the Eagles beat the Bears,
I was so excited
and then I realized
that Allie spent
our money on Chicago.
So I went back to him this week
and I reminded him
of the luck of Nick Foles
and I tried to convince him
to start bettin' on the Birds.
Thought the Bears
were gonna cover, Allie.
I thought the Bears
were gonna cover, pal.
"Oh, man, the Eagles
have no chance.
The Eagles are gonna lose."
Did you see that game?
- Yeah, I did.
- Did you see that doink-doink?
- Double-doink.
The Eagles again,
cuz they won
are goin' to New Orleans
a place where they lost
by 41 points earlier this year.
They started off
as a 10-point dog.
It's come down.
I'm giving it to you
as an eight-point dog.
Saints are favored by eight.
Drew Brees at home after a bye.
Heck, they rested Week 17 too.
- Eagles going to New Orleans.
- Going to New Orleans.
- Who Dat City.
- Saints off a bye.
- So they might be
a little rusty
but I like Drew to come through.
Covering eight against your Eagles.
- This is perfect.
This is what I needed.
Eagles are winnin'
this one, too.
Yes!
Allie, you superstitious!
Allie is a mush!
He's a mush!
He's a mush now!
- Yo, I'm not gonna lie
when you walked in, Adam,
I was like
"I'm goin' with the Eagles."
Then I thought about it.
I'm like, "Nah, you gotta
go with Drew."
- I get it.
I get it.
Magic.
- Eight points is a lot!
Did I just mess up?
Oh, man.
- So for the second
straight week
even though I told him
not to do it
Allie is bettin'
against the Birds
and he's takin' the Saints.
- OK.
- And you're probably
gonna side with him again.
- What's the spread?
- Eight.
- Eight?
OK, I'll give you this.
I'll take the Eagles
to cover the spread
but that's all
you're gonna do.
Sorry.
- Guess what?
I'm a gambling guy.
- I'm gonna do the L Dance
on here next week.
- What's the L Dance?
- You go like this.
My kid taught it for me
in Fortnite.
Yeah.
- I'm sitting here next to a guy
who's doing Fortnite dances
from his kid
who wants to give me
the gracious decision
of giving me the spread.
- Right.
- I don't just want the spread.
- Good.
- You know what line I want?
The money line.
- Ohh.
- Why?
Because the Eagles
and Nick Foles are continuing
their reign on the NFL,
and nobody can stop them.
And what are you doing?
- I'm doing my hat.
Let's go Saints!
I can't take Lefkoe anymore!
- Are you kidding me?
Who gave him this?
- Thou shall not beat thy Saints
and thy Drew Brees.
- I am gonna steal all of this
from you—
- Troll him!
- Cuz the Jack Boys.
- Troll him, Saints fans!
- Look how dumb he looks in that.
I look really intelligent.
- You look better. Yeah, you look better.
It's an improvement.
Good job.
- The Eagles.
You know what's weird?
- What?
- Is I wanna say they're gonna win
but I don't wanna jinx them.
- Oh, OK.
It's all about you.
- So that's my real superstition.
- That's right.
- For Simms.
- Peace out, homies. Go Saints!
- I am the L-E-F-K-O-E.
- Man.
Let's go Saints!
- He doesn't really root
for the Saints.
- I really want the Saints.
- Really?
- Yeah, I do.
- Damn.
- I can't hear you. I don't wanna hear it anymore.
- Enjoy the games. Go Birds.
- Had enough of this Eagles crap.
What do they call that, a muse?
Or what do they call that
when a, like, a Kim Kardashian
wears, like, clothes for a company?
- Yeah, not a muse.
A model.
Uhh, I don't know.
- It's a word like—
- Brand ambassador.
- No. It's something else.
It's a word.
I think it's still a muse.
I think it's—yeah.
I'm reading it—a noun.
It says, "Especially a woman—"
- "I'm reading it's a noun."
- "Who is a source
of an artist's inspiration."
- Hey, thanks for watching
"Simms & Lefkoe."
This Kim Kardashian conversation
is the perfect way
to close out the Wild Card
Round into divisional.
Have a great day.